welcome back there's a health insurance
team serving the valley that's all about
alignment
and access for seniors here's more
information
it is enrollment period for everybody
out there um so let's talk about
what alignment health plan does for the
community what a lineman health plan
does is we offer
medicare advantage plans that cover the
medical and sort of prescription
drug coverage for clark county residents
who are eligible for medicare
and i think one of the unique things
about alignment health health plan is we
were
founded on really one simple core
principle
and that is to put the senior first and
we really do that by focusing
in on what seniors really need working
with their doctors
the hospitals within the network to make
sure we can offer sort of the best
care and service experience that we
really feel is
pretty much like unlike any other plant
option in the market today
absolutely and and what what
differentiates alignment health plan
from the others
around town at alignment health plan we
believe
access to care and services is really
what separates us apart
and we do this by providing access and
services
over the phone in person in a doctor's
office
online and even in our patients homes we
have
clinicians and care providers that go to
our patients homes when it's necessary
and we really feel that's a
that's a differentiator one of the
interesting things this year that we're
introducing
three new plans in the clark county
market
is our ava hmo plan and the ava hmo plan
why that's really interesting rocky is
it's a
virtual first health plan medicare
advantage
all of our members have access to what
we call our concierge on demand services
24-hour services where we have a rep
because we understand that
your need to access care isn't just from
like 8 am to 8 pm
or during your doctor's office it's a
24-hour experience and we're here for
our members 24 hours
and we also feature what we call our
black card which is
a card all members get at no additional
cost with a lot of benefits and services
that come with that black card it's
really really cool
everybody wants a black card right there
you go
and what would you tell our viewers who
are um trying to decide what to do
during medicare's open enrollment period
you know 2020 has obviously been
a really overwhelming year and this just
adds to it
so i'd say look at cost look at access
additional benefits and if your doctor's
in hospitals are in your network but i
encourage one everybody
every single year to review their
healthcare coverage because things
change
every year this year is a really
important example of why that's
important
for more information call 1-888-979-2247
they're open from 8 a.m to 8 p.m seven
days a week except for thanksgiving and
christmas so keep that in mind we'll be
right back